former First Lady Michelle Obama who is
known for choosing her battles very
carefully is revealing her personal
feelings about President Trump in her
new memoir the washing post has just
published an excerpt from becoming
before it's official release on Tuesday
mrs. Obama writes about the president
for pushing the false idea that Barack
Obama was not born in the United States
and therefore was ineligible to be
President she calls it crazy and
mean-spirited dangerous and deliberately
meant to stir up the wingnuts and coops
mrs. Obama writes what if someone with
an unstable mind loaded a gun and drove
to Washington what if that person went
looking for our girls Donald Trump with
his loud and reckless innuendos was
putting my family's safety at risk and
for this I'd never forgive him according
to the AP the former first lady also
writes that she quote buzzed with fury
after seeing the Access Hollywood tape
where the president bragged about
manhandling women in 2005 she accuses
mr. Trump of trying to stalk Hillary
Clinton during one of their presidential
debates mrs. Obama claims the
president's unspoken message appearing
in darkened print is quote I can hurt
you and get away with it the White House
has declined to comment on that her book
is already tracking to be a huge huge
bestseller people have already
pre-ordered it when it drops on Tuesday
she normally doesn't engage this way but
clearly she has a lot to get off of her
chest I think she's just making the
point more largely that words matter yes
and that they would have a lot of power
yeah they're not just rhetorical that
sometimes they lead to action and that's
a conversation worth worth discussing a
lot of people were waiting to hear from
her and she's not holding back no she's
not